I want to take people out of their heads
I want origins to inject people with a
sense of wonder origins is the journey
of humankind it's basically show that
reinvents the sort of historical epic
from a modern perspective so through a
modern lens we look back at our origins
essentially how we became who we became
with episodes such as the origin of fire
and how that made us human or the origin
of war or the origin of Medicine how
these were transformative pivotal events
in human history so essentially the
origins of what made us human
if people have seen brain games they're
obviously aware that I'm very passionate
about making complex ideas accessible i
think when people watch origins they're
going to recognize a lot of what they've
seen me doing on the web expanded into
long-form the idea is to help people
transcend the the been there and done
that of the adults mind the sense that
we know it all the sense that we've seen
it all the sense that we understand at
all and it's gonna be like epic and
explosive and heady and it's gonna blow
people's minds
[Music]